yesterday we learned that mark milley
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff is
a danger to the country that was not
totally surprising we already knew he
was a reckless nutcase in june in the
middle of a televised congressional
hearing merely leveled a racial attack
against more than half of this country
millie told congress that something
called white rage was a national crisis
he never proved it or even defined the
term and yet still he kept his job which
says as much about congress as it does
about him then in july we learned that
mille had suggested the u.s military was
willing to use violence against donald
trump who was then the sitting president
we're the guys with guns he told fellow
officers
still congress did nothing
now thanks to a new book by bob woodward
and bob costa we've learned that millie
secretly collaborated with our greatest
military rival the government of china
on october 30th last year according to
the book millie called his counterpart
in china a chinese general he did not
tell his boss about the call
either before he made it or after he was
millie's message for the chinese
military we're not going to attack or
conduct any kinetic operations against
you generally you and i have known each
other for five years if we're going to
attack i'm going to call you ahead of
time it's not going to be a surprise
it's hard to believe that conversation
actually took place but apparently it
did more than 24 hours after it was
reported mark milley has not denied it
instead his spokesman released a
statement today confirming that millie
does regularly speak to chinese military
officials but claiming that those calls
are authorized by civilian leaders at
the pentagon but that turns out to be a
lie
just hours ago the former secretary of
defense christopher miller
told fox news he has no idea what mark
milley is talking about quote as
secretary of defense i did not and would
not ever authorize such conduct as
miller put it quote a lesser ranking
officer accused of such behavior would
immediately be relieved of duty
but mark milley has not been relieved of
duty and apparently he won't be today
joe biden endorsed him and the job he's
doing
sergio do the right thing thank you
thank you thank you
i
[Music]
so for secretly revealing american
military strategy to the chinese
government for threatening violence
against a sitting american president
mark milley is not going to be punished
are you surprised by this maybe you
shouldn't be in washington this is
normal colluding with the chinese
government is not considered a sin it's
not even weird
watch this video of millie from 2015 as
he explains that china somehow is not a
threat to
us is russia a greater threat to the u.s
than isis right now
i said in testimony that i considered
russia
the number one threat to the united
states russia
is the only country on earth that has
the capability to destroy the united
states of america it's an existential
threat by definition
china is not an enemy they are going to
develop themselves and are developing
themselves
into a great power
that is not to say however that they are
an enemy and it is not to imply nor say
that conflict with china is inevitable
so milli thinks china is winning and so
he's sucking up to his new masters so he
tells us quote russia is the only
country on earth that has the capacity
to destroy the united states
that's absurd
nobody believes that the chinese
military is far far more powerful than
anything vladimir putin controls it's
not even close
milly knows that he's lying about it and
that should make you very nervous why is
he lying about that no one in congress
seems to care at all people with
oversight seem to be on his side
this morning tom cotton the republican
senator from arkansas came on fox and
friends to talk about mark milley here's
part of that conversation
this book raises some serious concerns
i'd say some of the allegations seem
somewhat far-fetched to me but general
milley and secretary austin are going to
be testifying in front of congress in
just a few days and we'll address these
concerns uh we don't want to jump in
conclusions yet i know he will address
it and will ensure that he addresses it
but this is one of those claims
obviously that seems a little
far-fetched the idea that an american
military general is going to warn an
adversary if an attack is coming as you
say when donald trump was never even
thinking about a military attack against
china the whole thing is pretty
far-fetched
oh we don't want to jump to conclusions
yet really what conclusions
at the time that interview took place
this morning it had already been
conclusively established that mark
milley was pushing open racism on the
united states military that he had
bragged to fellow officers about
resisting the american president with
guns
and that he had told military officials
that he not the president controlled our
country's nuclear arsenal
how much more evidence do you need
exactly and why does no one in
washington consider this a crisis the
leadership of the pentagon
some of them anyway constitute a threat
to the united states hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else